le désespoir d'un amour à sens unique où
l' envie de tout faire sauter qu'a donc
motivé le passage à l'acte d'yves naudé
de son box le cinquantenaire déclare je
n'ai pas pensé au danger que ça pouvait
représenter pour les autres je ne suis
pas quelqu'un de violent
un avis que ne partage pas nadège elle
était sa voisine et s'est retrouvé
enseveli sous les décombres
le jour de l'explosion pour moi c'était
une bande une bombe à retardement
c'est quelqu'un qui pouvait se mettre en
colère très facilement pendant
l'explosion où on en est en train de
nous extrême du bâtiment quand on lui a
posé la question que voilà ce que
j'étais sous les décombres il a dit il
faudrait qu'elle crève en fait et pour
moi ça aussi une violence le psychiatre
qui l'a examiné par le d'un parcours
chaotique 10e d'une fratrie de douze
enfants
fils d'un père alcoolique et violent
yves naudet n'a jamais eu de situation
stable sur le plan professionnel comme
dans le domaine sentimental
l'expert décrit une personnalité
paranoïaque ce qui altère son
discernement sans toutefois le rendre
inconscient des conséquences dramatiques
de son acte c'est pas pelé dablé
entendable qui n'est pas eu conscience
des conséquences d'une explosion gaz mme
vien c'est quelqu'un qui était bricoleur
qui connaît c'est quand même les
rudiments et tout un chacun sait bien
que le gaz est une matière dangereuse et
qu' on s'amuse pas manipuler du gaz
comme ça sans risque et sans conséquence
pour autrui
hier l'accusé a présenté ses excuses aux
victimes ce qu'il n'avait pas fait lors
du premier procès pour savoir si cela
pèsera en sa faveur et bien il faudra
attendre le verdict il est prévu demain
après midi